[Music]
in inner beauty news all that matters
are you fine on a minute almost a minute
why we love Anthony really things you
just made that up I saw in a submission
so behind me oh well is it really
we know you're doing relative thank you
then you can have my back dude I would
appreciate that even if it's a lot you
made his day look at his clearest words
down he likes [ __ ] jakey it went in
his own question that really well I
figured well you know thank you
that's the most important topic inner
beauty to I mean come on
and all my dating apps has used to
seduce each other before they can see
their pictures very cool no what did you
connect like crazy but it's like the
quadrant overall yeah I like that
because I feel like so many people rely
on the looks of like tinder bumble or
whatever but like once you match like
there's such scale latent people that
they don't they can't even have a normal
conversation with you think you want to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] Quasimodo they open
that's really gonna [ __ ] anything I need
like Pyramid glad we said that out good
job before you go now you know anybody
who doubted but like you you have to
have some sort of comedic banter or
connection or something so I like I like
it I like it
good for you I kind of greet
because sometimes if I really connect
with a girl and she's not the best
looking girl in the world she starts to
become hotter and hotter and hotter
right and then if she's also a great
[ __ ] provider then it's also like wow
like
guys it's like wow yeah I feel anger
then you someone you could like there's
been times when I'm like damn she's
[ __ ] hot you see this girl for the
first time you're like oh my god oh it's
my friends friends friend please
introduce me right and then you're just
like oh [ __ ] we're finally hanging out
and in the first five minutes I'm like
god damn what the [ __ ] you opened up
your mouth and now you ruined life for
me
right cuz you're a [ __ ] weird sack of
[ __ ] you never had that virtually it
works to have you around a friend that
you were just friends and then you're
like oh right here yeah Jill's a friend
[ __ ] yeah your friend [ __ ] you [ __ ]
provider not a good [ __ ] provided we see
that's awesome buddy was ugly I thought
knowing my patient is a game but yeah
yeah I mean yo you guys saw like I was
[ __ ] fun-ass ugly too but like you
know we've evolved that's all I think
the crap though is not it's not like
you're building a friendship and then
maybe we will provide sucks for each
other it's like already in the context
of I'm looking for a particular type of
love right so it doesn't work there's a
negative - it's like it's like more
idealist in an idea but like what if you
seduce each other with community dancer
and conversation and things are great
and then you unfortunately let down and
and a shallow that seems like it's a
truth - yeah that's human nature I think
you're like oh I gotta break it off
because like [ __ ] busted yeah it is
what it is and then definite is even
deeper down the rabbit hole it's not
even like you didn't swipe for me and
then I never knew it's like Jane we had
a great connection and like you're that
shallow yeah it does that clarifies even
more I think this is for the people that
have been on tinder and they had no
success because it's always hot people
with no good conversation they're
looking for another different approach
yeah but I'm guessing that means that
the people that specifically use this
app will eventually like it all busted
this is the + mm
all right if that serious is possible a
lot of this is just a OM okay back in
those days not everybody had it together
everybody had pictures and all that
stuff I'm going to take you back to a 12
year old news is also way more room for
catfishing though right well let me tell
you this I would take you back to 12
year old Joe who had a strong connection
as well as he thought on the AOL days in
the chat rooms with a girl that lived in
the San Gabriel bull of San Diego area
we had a great connection and she sent
me her pictures vi8 mail mail and I
decided to never talk to her again
oh I'm not shallow I was honest I said I
don't think it's gonna work for my list
I live in the South Bay at the time okay
it was a to was 30-minute Drive I was 12
years old but here's the thing I was so
convinced that not only was this girl
perfect and the way that she described
her was perfect I was imagining like
this image of someone that was super hot
and finally we connect I get this
picture and she literally looks like
she's 9 years old and I was like [ __ ]
you told me you were 12 - or like 13 and
then you know asian girl kind of looked
like their mom still dresses them
sometimes so like I was going to school
with a lot of black and latina girls
they're more developed so I was thinking
like this is what a regular
thirteen-year-old is or 12 and then I
see her and I'm like you look like a
[ __ ] child
maybe I got catfished but at the same
time I was like this is weird I'm happy
yeah I don't know I think the reason why
this app just doesn't work for me
personally is because in my life
everything that whether it's a purchase
I rent something I just I test it out
first
I see it I look at the product I looked
at like I look at the house I'm in a
rent I'm looking to look at the car that
I'm about to buy it like dude I may
never make a long-term commitment I want
to see what the [ __ ] I'm getting first
and I mean you got to see a dick no I
don't care about the dick
always you got to do a test ride no I
don't care about that like
that's me is secondary but they have to
I have to be attractive to them I got to
be sexually attracted to them
yeah and like like mentally I have to be
stimulated by them
and so it I can't more modest you what
if he was a greasy nasty lard [ __ ]
[ __ ] but okay there's potential people
out there just because the overweight
doesn't mean that they utterly true
choose they got a beautiful face but you
go but you know what those three roles
under your chin mmm true and I think I
would give that relationship maybe like
a year and it's nothing changing on my
bra like that you're not changing you
had potential but I'm moving on right I
would still give them a kind of question
for the app yes
um at what point do they reveal their
identity so I'll tell you everything
about this I know when this app is so
specific that the first day she could
speak just full times app is called
answer Appetit
I'll like apple juice all those like
abstinence but it's Apple I was thinking
more like appetite impotence they gotta
give it a name is spelled AP PE te e de
an object competent assets like
acceptance for a nap oh it's a web -
you're a bad name yeah you know Meghan
you're uh you're ugly guys dream come
true what is that could they think that
with their personality and they can win
you that's you yeah Wow brand-new brawls
that's a new Legacy you're gonna have
like a [ __ ] ton of dudes that are like
yo I got I got dope personality I got no
personality yeah I'm gonna change my
Twitter bio yeah not the guys dream your
kicker where the guys ain't come true so
this app is a dating SS designed around
the principle of taking it slow and so
what you do is that you start off by
downloading this app off of iTunes and
then gradually
you gotta download 32k take your time so
you start to register on this app and
this app will ask you like a whole bunch
of questions like your interest and you
know like music foods like pets like oh
like where your location is your age
like your services ASL ASL and so on
then like they'll start
matchmaking you right and then you'll
start talking to these people and the
only way that you can unveil a photo is
if you actually have at least 100
messages or 100 around we know and in
order to reveal that photo at least you
need at least 50 likes in within the
messages or as they call it encounters
in this like I like what you said yeah I
like what you say I like what you said
like I started thinking in my head like
there must be a loophole like whatever
letter by letter yeah like like like
like hey what if I was getting catfished
by a man and I found out that I love
them but I didn't I'm not I didn't
realize I was gay what's going to happen
and you wouldn't evolve that would be
here evolute looks like a Pokemon that's
for you to answer what what happened
then I'll be [ __ ] sucking some dick
oh so you get like a little bit yeah
ping deleted like this I don't like that
and add you get like it like slowly and
build yes Lily our day is nice little
reverse puzzle like it's a normal puzzle
you know someone's going to be an
[ __ ] remove it and then [ __ ] put
it on Photoshop and then just fix it up
like not you agree if I was well I would
[ __ ] take a picture of my dick and
once they get to know me for oh my god I
am so into this I almost want to
download it to try it out to see what
it's lovely guys there it is
I think if I hit this either I would do
a little bit differently instead of
going by lights and interactions it
would be whenever the two people want to
see each other so they start talking
whatever and if one person's already and
the other person is always ready then
BOOM
yeah I think that would be better if you
don't know how conversations are going
to progress so I think it'd be better
it's mutual between the tooth is
obviously people to others out there
trying to find real love or whatever so
you should put it in the hands of the
people that actually doing it rather
than liking so that's not realistic
interaction so then the argument of that
would be that there's a lot of dating
apps I can already do that right away
where you can just already feel like
prisoner like we have communication
where you can see each other and how
each other looks like and so for this
this point is us no you can't do it the
way that I'm doing it ah so two people
download you can't see it they're
talking but what at any time yeah some
people fall in love really fast right so
any time that they're ready this person
can say I'm ready this person says I'm
ready as soon as two people agreed to
see each other then you could see on
both sides kind of kind of like um in
common good kind of attended kinda like
tinder in a sense right I do that one
week life and like both people I applied
to the same direction that's when you
get to but you put in the control of the
protein oh it looks like I never use
tinder ever aren't you guys so lucky not
because I'm too famous dude now if I use
Tim tinder I had to be timber I have to
be in a place that's like not a bunch of
Asians I feel like because it's just
weird like what if you run it it's just
when you use tinder you want to be a
person that is not known mmm you just
want to meet people so imagine like
being the rock yeah it's like you can
use tinder that it has um riah that
sounded like a fart
what's Riya what is Ryan um I guess it's
the tinder for famous people oh I think
it's be invited or something oh yeah I
don't want to work I got an ADA
yesterday and they brought it up and I
didn't know what it was and then I
figured it out by context clues or you
can have like 10,000 followers and then
you can get it
that makes it really yeah I don't like a
lot of people they all have a look at
you have a bed no no you just said I'll
take all days not that no and now you
have it ate myself Wow okay guys I hope
you enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]